c'est
ça t'arrive de paban des ouïes demandera
par exemple voyager revient avec chez
moi donc ce show peut empêcher tout ça
mais une fois dans l'île arrivait plus à
bander du coup normal je le branle tu
vois généreux merci mais ça marchait pas
ça a duré gp genre un quart d'heure
vingt minutes facile un peu long il
avait mis de la musique on s'est tapé
genre quatre chansons des red hot et
deux pubs 10h04 61,2 pub 10e est rien
ben en fait j'avais tout le temps
l'impression que ça allait démarrer
parce qu'il avait une sorte de carte de
mode une petite étincelle de trique
mais ça démarrait pas un peu comme toi
et ton bar de quelqu'un mais attention
le barbecue va démarrer mais alors le
pire c'est quand il a essayé de mettre
une capote
alors que clairement il était pas on a
tendance à faire cela
et des fois ça marche bon pourquoi vous
tentez alors si ça marche pas le geste
le challenge
on veut que les premiers accomplir
quelque chose pourquoi on escalader le
kilimandjaro
pourquoi est ce qu'on a fait du dos
crawlé jusqu'à l'angleterre parce qu'on
veut à des héros de la vie de tous les
jours où je veux être le premier à
réussir sa et sortir dans la rue
le monde s'arrête toile laissent tomber
leur café fond c'est lui l'homme qui
réussit à mettre une capote
même si bord des pod ouf pas comment il
a fait comment ils y ont fait on ne sait
pas personne ne le sait mais c'est pour
ça que tu porte son prénom
bon certes mais hier c'était juste
triste tu mettais 2,1 à côté de lui on
aurait dit une épreuve de fort boyard et
essayer chez pas lui donner un coup de
main mais oui oui je vais donner un coup
de main je dis j'ai fait que ça pendant
20 minutes
non mais un coup de main avec la bouche
je suis pas spécialement une romantique
je demande pas des pétales de roses des
bougies tout ça mais met dans ma bouche
une tête moins 80 de liquide séminal pas
mon gros kiff non plus pas façon ça
marche jamais vrai un side poste qui
fait quoi te raconte arrive pas bander
moi non plus pas un grand romantique
mais j'ai des techniques
je ferme les yeux je respire je pense à
des choses apaisante agréable excitante
et ça fonctionne pas un job presse la
base je rentre un pouce je rentre je
sens le pouce je me mets en étau et je
frétille comme seul ou au bas bas gauche
droite gauche doit normalement ça passe
et tu fais ça
quel sens dorment j'imagine mon nom une
chanson déjà d'autres plus ou moins
après c'est bon ouais bon en même temps
quand je commence à durcir je sais que
je joue exactement 10 rebonds et en fait
ça va le dire les pires coups de
l'univers c'est toi le timbre qui
viendra aider le pire couple uni veulent
allumer le barbecue giga leur ferme bien
ta gueule
c'est ensuite arrêté
une mission encore une il me faut
l'aimer